blade Smiths welcome to the forge
gentlemen in our first round of
competition today we're not going to
make you Salvage steel from junk instead
we're going to give you
these
crucibles crucibles have been used by
Smiths since the Bronze Age all the way
up to the Iron Age in the invention of
Steel a crucible is a staple in any
Smith's Forge and in your first round of
competition today you will secure one of
these crucibles smash it and then using
the steel inside of your Crucible to
make a signature blade and your
signature style that is between 12 and
14 in in length or 3- hour Starts
Now grab your pot grab your
pot is Crucible another word for uh blad
Smith's pinata with goodies yeah
right I have a pile of square pieces of
Steel how am I going to be able to stack
these up in weld these it's just an
awkward size and awkward shape Payton's
been over at the welder for a while he's
got a lot of tiny little cubes to weld
together I think he's got about eight of
them and I am thrilled that I picked
what I got I do layer Damascus this is
what I hoped I would get Jason has the
easiest cuz you already got your stuff
cut it's already the length my game plan
with this steel is just to stack it draw
it out and start forging my blade out as
I'm stacking the steel together I want
to make sure that everything is straight
and flat and that there's no voids in
between the steel because if there's
something trapped in between the layers
it's not going to turn out right what I
love about blad smithing is being able
to take raw materials and turn it it
into pretty much a piece of art
had those ball bearings he was working
with the hardest of all are the three
ball bearings cuz you got to do
something with those personally I'd
spend the time to turn them into
rectangles right now I'm going to try to
get two of them out to Bill it size fors
well them together to be able to meet
the
parameters I've got to really try to pay
attention and hope I don't get a cold
shut in the steel once I Forge weld it
together hopefully these two work and if
not I still have that one ball bearing
if all else
fails right now I'm hoping to make all
of these individual pieces of Steel one
solid
bar now I can concentrate on turning it
into a knife that is a nice looking buet
solid all the way through nice even
coloring I've got my two ball bearings
welded together I go over to Big Blue to
start forging it to shape and I noticed
that I have a
dam it's significant enough I don't
think I can grind past it I'm really
trying to salvage the piece that I'm
working with cuz I've got a lot of time
in it and I definitely do not want to
start
over I feel like I've gotten rid of most
the dambs and so I start to forge out
the
shape okay I look at the clock and then
I look over that power ham I'm like all
right it's game
time I'm feeling a lot better it's a
knife
now everything's straight no cracks now
I can start working on the Aesthetics of
it something's going on in there he's
got a bad weld I just had a complete
failure on my Forge
weld but I don't have time to chase this
has he abandoned the blade I don't know
I have no other choice but than to use
my last ball bearing and start over
there's not enough Steel in that 2in
ball bearing to make a 12 to 14in Blade
I'm going to stretch it out and see if I
can make it
happen the quench is vital because if I
don't have a strong blade if it's not
hard and it's just a piece of mild steel
like there's no reason to continue this
competition if I can't get get that
blade
hard think she's
hard all right it's it's straight I'm
good as I draw it out I realized that
I'm not going to have enough blade
length and so I know I'm going to have
to incorporate the rebar into the tank
section to be able to meet parameters
and have a handle it looks like Mitch is
going to use the work stick as his tank
rebars hold up skyscraper so I think
that's smart
move 5 Four 3 two one blad Smith shut
down your machine stop what you're doing
this first round of competition is over
L Smiths welcome to the strength test
the fire break
chop to test the strength and durability
of your Edge as well as the overall
construction of your knives I'll be
bashing them into these fire bricks
remember this test is all about what
those bricks do to your knives and not
with your knives do to the bricks Jason
you're up first how you feeling a little
nervous I'm ready I appreciate your
honesty well Jason got a major
problem there's a reason but caps are
there it's to deal with some of the
stress that's going through your handles
here what's remaining of the handle has
separated from the guard meaning if I
were to swing it one more time it's just
going to become a
projectile all right Jason big problem
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
failure in the handle and can no longer
continue with testing you went four
strikes on those fire bricks so you're
not out of this competition yet you
gentlemen have to survive four fire
break chops in order to move forward in
this competition so let's get it started
pyton you're up next
Ben after seeing Jason's handle fall
apart I'm a little bit worried got these
weld lines in there maybe they could
fail my handle isn't perfect I mean me
it could blow apart too just as well as
his I have no idea what could
happen well pton you survived well done
thank
you me you you ready for four yes sir
all right let's do
it the biggest thing I'm worried about
is having some type of structurer issue
with my handle I had a really hard time
getting the pommel to stay on so I'm not
100% sure how secure the handle is I was
super nervous I bricks fire bricks over
that
well Mitch she held up well done thank
you all right blad Smiths what we have
here is two blades that can continue
with testing Jason unfortunately your
blade cannot and therefore please leave
the forge come on forward my friend was
a great blade thank you I got caught up
on certain things that I should have
tried to speed through a little bit
quicker and before long I I was out of
time good luck bab thanks you kind of
get in a panic mode and start putting
stuff together that you normally
wouldn't do and that's the
[Music]
results
a